you are not the most popular or
memorable person to have ever lived on
this planet but who is well mit's
Pantheon might have the answer it
considers the endurance and breadth of
the fame of more than 70 000 members of
our species and according to their
methods the 10 most well-known and
memorable humans to have ever existed so
far are Alexander the Great Marco Polo
Ludwig von Beethoven Plato Aristotle
Leonardo da Vinci Genghis Khan Jesus
Isaac Newton and at number one Muhammad
you can search rankings by gender
occupation birth year they even have a
game called berthal the most globally
recognized person born in the 90s is
Brazilian footballer Neymar and as for
people born in the 2000s Noah Joop
crucially amongst YouTubers at rank 32
there's a hunk and a half
oh